[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen ich weiß
dass du da bist
das weiß ich auch weil ich dich in der
letzten folge umgedreht habe ich wünsche
einen schönen tag wir sehen uns mister
papa ich habe vor heute ein riesiges
projekt vor
und das sind bereits im titel
eingeblendet denn ich möchte heute
endlich unsere villa fertigstellen
da haben wir ja noch immer nicht das
dach fertig gebaut wir haben das
interieur noch nicht fertig und ich weiß
dass wahrscheinlich sehr lange dauern
wird und die folge wird heute vermutlich
für mich und das kann sein aber ich
setze mir lieber zu hohe ziele setzen
und die nutzen um teil erreichen als das
ihr euch ein kleines zielsetzung das
erreicht die komplette gibt die gleiche
anspornen arschloch ich bin noch weg
meine lieben freunde euch direkt jetzt
eine riesige teile die ich in die hölle
gehe und quarz farmer da ich nun
wirklich eine stunde lang im nada quad
fahren war
habt ihr euch mal erhielt er einen witz
von mir verdient uns warten leute ich
kann
wirklich immer noch nicht fassen dass
die nach dem ganzen scheiß wieder
zusammen sind
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich von
wem ich rede
von meinen arschbacken o mein gott
freunde eine komplette stunde eine
stunde und zehn minuten lang war ich
gerade mit sandra hier unterwegs in der
hölle und habe ein zwei drei vielleicht
insgesamt 46 quartz abgebaut wirkt jetzt
nicht so viel liegt allerdings auch
einfach daran dass ich mit meiner glück
ein spitzer karrees abbauen musste ich
habe extra die glut dreispitz acke
diamanten und den amboss mitgenommen und
ich hier seht ihr auch und ich habe 45
level jedoch konnte ich trotzdem nicht
meine glück drei spitzhacke reparieren
minecraft hat mir immer gesagt mensch
egal
das ist zu teuer von laya freunde bitte
schreibt mir bitte bitte bitte bitte
natürlich ist auch wieder nacht bitte
schreibt wir uns in die kommentare was
ich falsch mache ich will meine glück
drei diamant spitzhacke zurück ich weiß
nicht ob die ob das mit der zunehmenden
nutzen nutzungsdauer mit zunehmender
nutzungsdauer
ob es dadurch teurer wird die jedes mal
zu reparieren
ich weiß dass jetzt wieder alles
schreiben werden du brauchst eine
reparatur buch blabla ja da arbeite ich
auf der anderen seite dran mit dem
bibliothekar können wir gleich mal ganz
kurz gucken ob der neue sachen hat
allerdings guck mal ich siebzehn amboss
hierhin packe die glücksspiel zu teuer
er ich habe 60 diamanten und 45 level
und das kann doch nicht sein also wir
gehen mal ganz kurz rüber zu unserem
bibliothekar und nehmen auch mal ganz
kurz einige smaragde mit dann kann ich
das hier eben ganz fix schon mal eben
abklären + ich kann mir hier vorne auch
schon eben die sachen wieder rausnehmen
und so ein bisschen glück schon mal
nachlegen
ich habe da extra lava einer eingepackt
in der letzten episode ja mitbekommen so
dass wir hier ein bisschen
mehr ja sag ich mal wo ist der rest ich
hab den habe ich in der letzten folge
schon raus genommen oder zu beginn der
folge ich weiß nicht damit wir auf jeden
fall ein bisschen mehr power haben die
wir packe ich auch mal ganz fix eben
zurück hier vorne zu den anderen quartz
blöcken wo haben sie denn hin gepackt
bin ich komplett um
[Musik]
ich beschloss eine stunde später die
waren noch in den öfen was ich alles
sagen was du lieber an das ganze noch
keinem erzählen warum guckt man sich die
projekte überhaupt an weil sich
allerdings gerade machen wollte war mal
kurz in ihre fragen ob er rückstoß
verbrennung sperrte drei auch sehr wild
aber sonst gar nichts das namensschild
brauchen wir allerdings trotzdem das
werde ich allerdings nicht jetzt kaufen
sondern in der nächsten episode was ich
da mal genau machen werde erfahrt ihr
dann
ich werde nun allerdings meine fahrt
glück nehmen beziehungsweise erst mal
ganz kurz vorstellen meine item
sortieren
so sieht unsere strandvilla aktuelle aus
da fehlt halt noch das dach oben und
darüber vergessen
ich brauche eine behutsamkeit spitzhacke
denn ich habe ja hier vorne noch eine
menge glas und ich will dafür eigentlich
nicht meine gold behutsamkeit spitzhacke
verschwenden weil die direkt wieder die
wird die rede direkt wieder kaputt von
daher würde ich sagen arbeiten wir jetzt
einfach mit eisen spitzhacken die wir
versuchen zu verzaubern von da nehme ich
mal ganz kurz meine specker dann nehme
ich hier die alten waren mit und ich
werde jetzt auch einfach mal die
werkbank mitnehmen so dass wir dann
alles nach vorne direkt auf der insel
machen können wir brauchen wirklich
behutsamkeit das war halt so nice oder
habe ich nicht noch irgendwas sie mit
behutsamkeit verzauberung drauf oder so
ist halt behutsamkeit drauf aber hier
ist eine effizienz und haltbarkeit
gelegt und jetzt ein ganz normaler also
eine spitzhacke also wir können auch
erst mal ganz kurz
unsere schuhe wieder tauschen die wache
ist ich bin schon total durch mit der
folge ich bin bei eineinhalb stunden
im video ist es wahrscheinlich
allerdings gerade minute oder irgendwie
so und das ist gerade so ein bisschen
das problem
ich will dieses video heute nicht kurz
halten weil ich eigentlich ja noch eine
menge schaffen muss mit der villa
allerdings werde ich jetzt erstmal ganz
kurz hier probieren mit der werkbank und
dann meiner neuen spitzhacke
behutsamkeit drauf zu bekommen also ab
rein den marsch und wir haben die
effizienz haltbarkeit und effizienz wie
können es halt probieren mit effizienz 4
noch nicht doch das wird nichts ich
glaub das wird nichts wir werden uns
dementsprechend darauf nachher
konzentrieren uns jetzt erstmal auf das
dach unserer villa konzentrieren das
habe ich zweimal konzentrieren sagt
fokussieren heute ford focus gesehen
alter tiefer gelegt so eine dreckskerl
sorry an alle die zu hause und ford
focus stehen haben
falls ihr euch jetzt grade beleidigt
haben sollte ist ein wunderschönes auto
allerdings sie kein auto extrem tiefer
gelegt in neongrün schön aus da kann es
auch ein porsche sein oder ein
lamborghini ja keine ahnung was ihr seht
schon ich brauche hier oben gerade mal
das dach so ein bisschen zu so dass wir
hier
auf jeden fall erstmal keinen regen mehr
im hause drin haben
die sache ist dass ich zu beginn ein
bisschen schiss hatte dass ich das
überhaupt schaffe mit der glücks ein
glück 1 spitzhacke den ganzen quatsch
abzubauen den wir benötigen für diese
strandhaus villa
die sache ist allerdings dass wir ja
auch noch hier oben gleich eine kleine
ja wie nennt man das so ein kleines
panoramadach einbauen werden und an der
seite auch noch von daher benötigen wir
eigentlich gar nicht so viele quads
blöcke wie ich mir das zu beginn gedacht
habe diese sechseinhalb spex was sich da
vor zwei folgen meinte sondern das
werden wir auch mit ein bisschen weniger
hinkriegen die habe ich mich gerade
zweimal verbaut
von daher kann ich euch schon mal sagen
hier vorne kommt gleich so eine wand aus
glas rein die wir hier über ziehen und
hier auch noch hier vorne in der ecke
das hier muss allerdings weg das lasse
ich jedoch jetzt erstmal geradestehen
und bist für das interieur machen in
einer der nächsten folgen ich weiß es im
titel steht die villa ist fertig die
sache ist allerdings dass ich damit
meine das im rohbau fertig ist also
interieur interior design kommt später
da werden wir uns nachher noch darum
kümmern wenn jetzt auch gleich mein
fahrlehrer ist werde ich direkt
drübergehen ich verbrauche ich auch die
ganze zeit ging wie gerade wenn man klar
ist welche auch rüber gehen wir das
andere quarz holen und dann noch mal
kurz ein bisschen glas machen damit wir
das vielleicht heute auch sogar schon
fertig kriegen mit denen glasfenstern
die sache ist jedoch ich sagte so auf
die sache ist allerdings oder die sache
jetzt jedoch oder irgendwie so ist er
hat ganz kurze time ist dass er
überhaupt nicht spannend heimlich hat
ihnen hierzu bauer den quartz wurde glas
mache und dann sehen uns sofort wieder
[Musik]
so ich konnte jetzt leider nicht das
komplette glas fertig machen was ich
benötige für meine villa allerdings ab
wo wir haben in gebieten mit gäste hier
heute mandant bitte habt ihr sollen sie
sich haben wir noch mehr wir haben noch
eins gelernt wer jetzt aber kein krieg
baut also das wird uns jetzt natürlich
komplett die tour versauen stuck hier
vorne erwartet auch niemand in dem raum
dahinter weiß nicht was da abgeht kommen
wir ganz kurz gucken aber extra fackel
neuen gesetz perfekt ja das glas hier
bräuchte ich eigentlich um das erst mal
ganz kurz hier oben alles zu bauen um
das hier vorne rüber zu bauen
die sache ist jetzt auch warum habe ich
mir den so viele glatte quartz blöcken
gemacht hast du bei der ich das hier
alles noch voll bauen musste dass ich
würde sagen wir jetzt erstmal unser gold
spitzhacke und machen das hier so gut es
geht ist das dein kaputtes das heißt
wahrscheinlich wir können ja acht blöcke
abbauen oder so wie ich unsere gold
spitzhacke kenne diese mich jetzt schon
wieder fast schrott und zwar genau kann
ich jetzt aufhören
ich dachte ein blog schafft die noch
jetzt ist einfach kaputt
naja ist hier vorne noch glas
reingefallen ja natürlich hier haben wir
noch ein glas blog hier und hier vorne
es scheitert halt nicht am glas dass
sich das mit dem mit der glas waren
heute nicht so richtig glaube ich
hinkriege es scheitert halt ganz einfach
daran dass ich keine tintenfische hier
sehe die ich leider töten muss um die
tinten beutel zu bekommen denn das ist
die einzige möglichkeit um einen block
schwarz zu färben und hier ist nirgendwo
weit und breit wenn tintenfisch und das
regt mich einfach extrem auf von daher
müssen wir jetzt erstmal leider mit dem
arbeiten was wir noch haben und daher
nun erstmal die glatten quartz
glückliche vornherein den rest hier
werde ich jetzt einfach dann abbauen
glaube ich habe ich gar keinen bock
drauf mich jetzt irgendwie lange damit
zu beschäftigen kann man glas eigentlich
in die schnell abbauen
ne ne kurze time labs
so meine lieben freunde wieder daheim
labs folge
ich glaube das video geht wie die ich
noch gar nicht lange allerdings habe ich
ja nicht nehmen das ganze jetzt schon
seit einer stunde 45 auf ich muss hier
vorne auf jeden fall erst einmal
provisorisch ein paar fackeln reinsetzen
so dass hier nicht 2000 am hellichten
tag ich sehe einen tintenfisch muss ich
direkt hin jetzt muss ich aber dass die
linke hand nehmen mir ist ja auch gerade
quartz blog runter gefallen ich weiß
nicht vorne ist perfekt doch jetzt
müssen wir ganz kurz wo habe ich ihn
gesehen bin ich blöd euren tintenfisch
[Musik]
da ist er auch h2 das heißt vielleicht
schaffen wir das doch mit der kompletten
fenster situation heute meine lieben
freunde hat allerdings gerade kein inc
gedroppt ich weiß nicht ob ich dann
einfach noch nicht aufgenommen habe oder
ist der esa perfekt sogar zwei stück
perfekt
hier vorne der bitte auch noch zwei
stück dann kann's wirklich was werden
heute mit den fenstern die schwimmen
immer extrem schnell weg man die einmal
steht nochmals zwei perfekt während ihr
stück seele vielleicht noch irgendwo
tintenfischen ist leider nicht der fall
von daher meine lieben freunde werde ich
mich nun hinten hin or mein gott ein
dritter tintenfisch alter also als in
minecraft mir gesagt hätte kommt luca
können die sieben stück habe ich da
hinten sogar noch ein denn finden noch
ein alter was geht denn jetzt hab ich
schwöre tablets eingewendet gesehen also
ich kann gar nicht getötet haben aber
ich hab die dann nicht hin platziert
oder irgendwas gemacht das ist einfach
gerade ist einfach wieder mein glück in
minecraft also ich habe sieben stück das
heißt ich kann damit erst mal nach ganz
hinten laufen ein bisschen glas holen
ich kann mir aus dem ganzen jetzt
eineinhalb sechs schwarzes glas machen
und ich glaube dass das zumindest für
die scheibe links erstmal reichen sollte
ich weiß jetzt was für das panoramadach
auf der anderen seite reicht allerdings
sehen wir ja vielleicht irgendwo noch
ein paar delfine 8b fiene sind infinite
vielleicht sehen wir irgendwo noch ein
paar tintenfische rom schwimmen dass wir
auf jeden fall extrem lies dann können
wir das machen ich habe auch den glatten
sandstein mitgenommen dann können wir
eventuell noch unseren kleinen
provisorischen sand hier noch ein
bisschen erweitern die freude kommt ja
noch ein pool hin kommt alles haben wir
heute nicht komplett vollenden
allerdings ist der rohbau heute auf
jeden fall erstmal fertig von daher
müssen wir uns nun erstmal nach hier
vorne bewegen ich habe mich auch schon
perfekt ausgebaut denn wir brauchen hier
123456 breit soll das ganze gehen dann
müssen wir das ganze jetzt hoch bauen
und jetzt von hier aus zehn blöcke rüber
in die richtung und diesen bereiche
jetzt füllen mit schwarzem glas so dass
das ganze dann schlussendlich so
aussieht und das wird von außen sowohl
als von ihnen auch extrem geil aussehen
ich beziehe man hier genau mal ganz kurz
eine fackel wie gesagt alles nicht
provisorisch das hat der boxer sind
ergeben allerdings sieht ihr schon das
siebte wild aus hier vorne hier kommt
dann noch eine kleine ablage hin und so
dass baum dann alles demnächst wie
gesagt interior design kommt noch
allerdings bauen wir jetzt für hier
vorne auch noch eine kleine glasfläche
reihen denn dafür setzen wir uns erst
mal 123 41 23 hier so eine kleine
markierung rein so dass wir genau wissen
wo wir das genau abbauen müssen
und jetzt in diesem bereich 1 1 2 3 4 5
mal 1 2345 großes quadrat also 12345 in
diese richtung dann 2345 hier rein dafür
habe ich jetzt leider zu wenig schwarzes
glas mit vielen genau drei stück und
hier vorne kommt auch noch was rein also
ich bin leider was das angeht gerade ein
bisschen schlecht aufgestellt ich bei
allerdings ganz kurz mal eben diesen
glatten sandturnier nochmal ab glatten
sandsteinen turm noch mal ab und hier
vorne damit sind wir gleich auch noch
was machen die sache ist allerdings dass
ich gerade irgendwo einen delfin gesehen
habe ich weiß jedoch nicht mehr wo das
war oder ob der wieder untergetaucht ist
habe ich dann leider verloren und dieses
eine diesen einen erfinden wollte
brauche ich wirklich noch dann habe ich
es für heute geschafft meine lieben
freunde
ich find ihn allerdings einfach nicht
ich weiß nicht warum ich jetzt gerade so
am struggle mit tinten beuteln ich hatte
doch irgendwie so viel schwarzes glas
dass ich wahrscheinlich ihren gebaut und
komplett verbaut
naja ich muss doch irgendwo noch ein
tintenfisch sein
dann bringen wir das auf jeden fall
heute noch werde ich noch einmal schön
um die villa rumpf irgendwie wir darum
unsere insel rum
allerdings kann ich euch gleich hier
vorne schauen wir die villa von dieser
insel hier zeigen so dass sie dann in
etwa ich schon vorstellen können wo die
reise hingeht also
ich bin ehrlich gesagt ich bin zufrieden
mit der villa ich hätte allerdings nicht
dass es so lange dauert es wird sehr
wild aussehen wenn da oben noch interior
drin ist sondern hier die fackeln weg
und so das wird sehr sehr geil hat nur
schade dass es jetzt irgendwie an
sondern ein bisschen glas hier habe hat
ist aber auch egal meine lieben freunde
dann soll es anscheinend nicht sein ich
nehme hier vorne mal eben noch fix die
sachen raus die hier noch drin waren wir
noch eine menge glas drin und ein
bisschen glatten sandstein ich schauen
aber kurz hier vorne ob wir irgendwann
tintenfisch ist die dieses youtube soft
zu blöd um hier rauszukommen ich hab ja
schon im block vorhin mal abgebaut
allerdings sehe ich hier wirklich kein
tintenfische wenn man die nicht braucht
dann schwimmen die überall rum diese
blöden thunfische aber mal dann braucht
man wieder von hinten wollten sie wieder
weg es habe keine ahnung was das hier
soll
warum ich jetzt hier so hopps genommen
werde von dem spiel mal wieder aber ich
hatte ja vorher auf dem riesigen
riesiges glück mit den ganzen
tintenfischen h einen ton versprochen
wir da noch das kann nicht sein sagt du
bist okay das ist natürlich auch eine
gute arten streits bösen ja meine lieben
freunde ich weiß ja wenn titel
geschrieben die villa ist fertig und die
villa ist auch mehr oder weniger fertig
also in sevilla von hier schon das sieht
brutal aus klar da oben die ja gerade
sandstein butterweck und hier kommt ein
anderer durchgang durch und ich habe
auch viel zu viel platz mittlerweile ich
habe noch dreieinhalb spex allerdings
will ich an der stelle des heutigen
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben freunde
ich habe auch eine kleine bitte an euch
denn für die nächste episode minecraft
mit luca habe ich mir gedacht mache ich
eine kleine fragerunde
und er schreibt mir jetzt eure fragen
bezogen auf dieses projekt und in die
kommentare des canvas mitschnitt zu tun
haben mit wie lang geht's noch mit
irgendwas was euch einfällt was euch
interessiert an minecraft mit lukas
schreibt mich an und in die kommentare
und wenn euch das video heute gefallen
hat dann das kann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video harmoniert main kanal
und klickt auf die glocke so dass ihr
die nächstes die nächsten part nicht
verpasst wo ich dann diese xxl fragen
mache übermorgen 20 uhr
[Musik]